noch stars und her lecker frühstück mein
neues auto smart ist von gestern
smart ist schon gestern dortiger
parkplatz einfach ins sind weg also noch
mal kurz elektroschock oder autofahren
dass er seine ruhe ja genau das einfach
so dann hat dein stadt setzt 1800 die
performance oder das ist ganz kurze info
übrigens für euch mal meine lieben
zuschauer heute kommt sandra die
begeisterung hält sich in grenzen da
kommt gleich nach hamburg gefahren weil
richtig weiß ich dass sie sieht einfach
aus wie styropor macht dafür auch etwas
gefunden
hinten noch sitze
politiker hätten sachen ja weil er fährt
jetzt groß
[Musik]
zu den kopf hoch bällen bald vielleicht
schon
[Musik]
er wollte vor 20 minuten hier sein und
ich musste die ganze zeit über facebook
und die gehen einfach nicht ran
schweizer also du warst auf der falschen
seite weiß so wie es dir auf gemalt habe
beriet der lauf über die ampel und dann
links 4
ich fühle mich echt verarscht manchmal
von der ich habe schon beim karstadt
daneben
ich habe keine ahnung hast du neues
parfüm oder deo kannst du davon hast du
dich für zucker besucht er gibt jetzt
ein paket an babbel
also es ist schon schön aus dem buch
hier ist auf youtube vergammelt und
irgendwie sind die menschen auch richtig
verkabelt
vielleicht gibt es später war vox sehen
weil wichtig bildung 150 und prügeln
es ist eine katastrophe
also schon fitter werden also immer ein
bis zweimal die woche sport machen kann
ich habe jetzt ein schiff mit extra end
mit damit auch wenn du kannst du unsere
welt erstmal muss man sagen sandra die
ipad mit reingenommen hat dann wird sich
angefangen spieler zu spielen besitzen
einen echten restaurant mit dem dann
hatte ich tee bestellt und getrunken
[Musik]
rund zu laufen dass wir uns wiedersehen
muss mal schön saufen machst etwas regen
draußen ist heiß soll ich kurz
aussteigen
[Musik]
nur mit euch anfragen meine küche
ich schaue mir zerkratzt stimmt gar
nicht ich hab natürlich nicht normal
gegessen sondern die jungen kissen
ich weiß nicht wo die kiste wie ihr
wisst dass ich mal eine kerze mit lukas
vergangenen füßen die hereinkommt die
täglichen alkoholika jedoch falsch beim
trinken vergehen denn hier mein kater
denkt auch dass er so erfolgreich ist im
eigenen bücher schreibt hier ist ein
stuhl oder auf dem pc die roten das also
ich hab auch was ganz besonderes
[Musik]
ich glaube das funktioniert so hat das
du mir mal gezeigt dass man spiegelt
sich diese taschentücher dahinten ich
bin aber auch gerade ein bisschen
erkältet das muss ich auch
ich bin ich natürlich nur oft weit
kannst klar ganz so günstig wurde jogo
vor dem jobcenter bekommt die so laut
ich meine szene
sandra braucht übrigens nicht mehr
und jetzt will sie mich davon überzeugen
wie die tiere das ist für wenn du
trinkst wird immer ein bisschen mehr
offen
und das ist fürchterlich am morgen du
kannst auch überlegen welche welche du
willst es gibt den daumen hoch wenn ihr
wollt dass luca eine zigarette anbietet
sag mal ich hätte nie waren das einzige
was ich jemals rauchen werde sehr tolle
raumduft von meiner luft kerze auf ihrem
ipad jetzt mein gesicht wir sehen uns
wieder wenn es fertig ist drei wochen
später hat mich fertig gemalt so wie es
aussieht
der hintergrund schwarz war luca
einsatzzeit depressiv ist weil er keine
frauen auch ich aber will es einfach
atom ihn gesehen wo einfach steht die
tatsache dass rtl now punkte ihr auch
unter rtl.de erreichbar ist sagt alles
aus was man bei rtl wissen muss von der
testung das jetzt einfach mal und geben
rtlnow.de ein und man wird
warum sagst du so war es also gerade
sagen dass wir von der ipad session
jetzt plötzlich star ryan dunn auf jede
beleidigung ein stuhl ist komplett
sauber haben die stuhl ist auch komplett
sauber an der stufe unheimlich freundin
es auch komplett sauber und auch sandra
stuhl ist irgendwie scheiße ich glaube
die hat ein kleines problem gibt sowie
bei ihrem abi und beim waschen denke das
ist einfach eine duftkerze die tut so
als wäre das eine droge
[Musik]
ich bin einfach so hübschen mein gott
wie kannst du dich von unten film sagen
[Musik]
ja
es warten würde
[Musik]
das könnte teuer sein
es ist 23 uhr 30 und sandra und ich
haben uns hat alles vorbereitet nehmen
jetzt noch eine podcast folge auf
beckett am horizont durch sein erstmals
krone